why don't we go next to Casey from
Kansas Casey from Kansas welcome to the
program let's hope and pray for no
technical issues Casey welcome you're on
oh dear Casey the most likely problem is
you've selected an audio device that's
not valid on your computer
hello can you hear me now I can hear you
oh you can sorry it took me a second
what's going on
I had a question relating to something
that's been asked in a few of the
communities I'm in recently okay mainly
the vosh or vouch Community is Ian vouch
of course yes Ian vouch
but would you consider the legislation
and the rhetoric from the GOP targeting
trans people to be a genocide in any
sense of the word uh you know these
these things are so fraught because
you can you can contrive and fabricate
some interpretation of so many things
where you could match it up with a
number of different words like for
example genocide speaking colloquially
and I know Casey you're not trying to
gotcha me right so it's like speaking
colloquially
I don't think that those are the right
words that I would apply to the
anti-trans legislation now can I like
can I imagine how someone might make
that connection can I propose to you how
I would do it if I wanted to make that
case you tell me if this is what's being
said
Casey
hello
uh hi okay can you hear me Casey
yeah a little bit I was having a little
bit of trouble okay yeah I think I can
hear you if I had to make the case that
anti-trans legislation is genocide I
would say something like the following
um
trans folks
have a high rate of suicide uh
attempting and suicidal ideation
and when you pass anti-trans bills that
make it more difficult for them to Avail
themselves of the medical or other
services that may help them
you increase the odds that they will
attempt suicide and thus one could argue
that those bills are in a sense a
genocide is that like roughly the way
one would do it is that how you do it
but also just like the like I don't know
if you could use like the term
legislative genocide or like yeah say
like there was a recent bill that was
proposed that would make it where
you can't do like transitional Health
Care even if you're 26 or under yeah
which is not even 18 like would that be
like genocide at all listen
this is it doesn't seem to me that the
word genocide is neither accurate in its
Spirit nor productive but of course I
can see how somebody might make us a
semantic argument of that kind it's not
really the way I kind of think about
these issues I think is where I would
leave it
okay do you at least think it's like a
dangerous warning sign at least yes and
also like when when a governor requests
a list of people who have transitioned I
think all those things are very
dangerous warning signs
okay well thank you Casey from Kansas
thank you very much I appreciate the
call